νος με την ένιαν δεν θα έχω χρόνο να κάτσο μόνος μου να χαραρώσω αλλά
θα πξομε το γιό μουθα με τιγινακα μου θα πάμε μασβει στο πάρκον ι μαζί
που μπορείνα νε κάτι που κάποιες φέρες κουράζεις ι σωματικά αλλά σίγουρα μου δίνει πολύ
υπερεξότερα νολητικά να βλέπεις πωςξέλισε το γέσμος ος μεγαλώνι η αγάπει οπο έχεις νάσω προσφέρει
να μπορών και σίγουρα και ο χρόος που περνόμερη σύζειόμου εναι πολύ ευνόμον για όσα
έχει προσφέρεικη στην οικογέννια που πορεί να νεκοσις ε το κοετράλομεμε το γιο μας και
εγώ να α να γάνω πρώταθυλητισμόκαι προτημασίας και είναι καθυμερώνει να ακριώς όταν είμαι μακριά
τους που είτε είναι φούλ προετιμασία που θα συγκετρόνεται εντελώσεις αυτό που κάνουμε αλλά θα
έχει έτσι πιο λευθέρο χρόνο που θα μπρώ να κάτσο να χαραρώσω ι δύο πολλές
φορές να τους πιάσω τηηλέφωνο ναδοτικά και ιαγόνα οιο είναι το γορι του πάύλο που
έχει πάντα μαζί του στη διάρκια ενοσαγόνα θαγιά μουν αρκετάμε αυτά τα πράτα έτσι ουπρεστήσος
τα ελεγα ήταν το καπέλαμου βλέων δέια το όνα καπελαμε γιατί οι αρκετές φορέσες τα
χάνεις μέσας τηθάλασαν τώρα τα επιγάσληπυακούα γόνε ο γιώς μας επέλεξε να μουδώσει για α
να από τα παιχνί διατούτο οποίον είχα μαζίμα και φάνηκε να γουρλίτι το έχες πάνω
στο κάφος μαζίναι πάνα αποτιάτ δεν κάνωλαστα μεταλλία ου κατέκτησε αλα αυτά τα χρόνια σε
μεγάλες δεργανώσειςδεν τα έχωμετρισή προσφατναμηνικανε αλλά πρέπει να είναι πανα αποτηριάτρια ξεχώρησηςσίγονα εταδύότα λιμπιακά θέλα
αποκεταρό τα μαγκρόνα πραθείών αλλά θα από το έναν απότερε μια σκειμο πεστριά του δεκαεφτάμια
σκετά στο ήταν το πρότομου και ήταν στο σπλήτο που στην πια μεγάλοσα εκεί και
αυτό πουμου έκαμετ